une nuit de recherches les pompiers ont
fouillé les décombres jusqu'à 4 heures
du matin pour trouver d'éventuels corps
humain à midi toutes les hypothèses sont
encore possibles jean pierre chevènement
le maire de belfort lance un appel à
témoin que j'ai demandé que les témoins
s'il y en a tous ceux qui ont des
éléments nous permettant de déterminer
les causes du sinistre se fassent
connaître et à les porter l'enseigné au
commissariat
c'est tout à fait un bon temps qu'on
sache exactement ce qui s'est passé
15h cet après midi avait sont les lieux
de la catastrophe
des experts de la police scientifique de
paris c'est eux qui devront déterminer
les causes exactes de la sont dits
déterminés également si les normes de
sécurité et à respecter cet ancien hôtel
avait été construit dans les années 20
puis rachetée par un marchand de biens
l'immeuble est ensuite vendue en
copropriété depuis 1982 les parties
communes étaient gérés par la g stream
la toiture la cage d'escalier et la
façade avait été rénové par le syndic
ces deux dernières années à ma
connaissance cet immeuble
en ce qui concerne ses parties communes
étaient en état convenable
je dois préciser que par contre en ce
qui concerne les parties privatives
le syndic de copropriété que kg stream
n'a aucun regard sur ces parties
privatives tous ces appartements
appartiennent à des co propriétaires qui
louent ou eux-mêmes ou en passant par
des agences mais il se trouve que notre
société jet stream ne gère ou qu'un
appartement dans cet immeuble
selon certains témoignages le feu aurait
pris dans les poubelles de la cage
d'escalier silence cet après-midi en
tout cas de la part des enquêteurs selon
le parquet rien ne permet de dire qu'il
s'agit d'un acte criminel
même si la série de feux de poubelles
perpétrés il y a quelques semaines dans
lé quartier des glacis et des résidences
à belfort est toujours inexpliquée
le juge d'instruction de belfort a été
saisie du dossier
une information a été ouverte